[Music]
my name is Rajiv Mahajan and I'm a
customer engineer in Google's retail
practice today we are going to be
talking about migrating on-premises
Hadoop infrastructure to Google cloud
platform let me introduce my
co-presenter up here I'm James Malone
I'm a product manager at Google cloud
platform IPM a couple of products one of
them is cloud data proc unfortunately
for you guys we've hidden all of our
secret new features in the side of the
slide deck here so we have a few other
presentations today where we will be
announcing all of our secret stuff so
you just have to kind of wonder what's
under the mysterious black box there
with that I'm gonna go ahead and turn it
over to you
Thanks so whenever you think about
migrating from on-premises clusters to
Google cloud platform there are three
aspects that you have to consider
migrating your infrastructure your data
and your jobs and that's what we're
going to talk about today okay there are
a few recommendations we are going to
make and we are going to stress them
over and over again in this presentation
and they are as follows first when you
are thinking about infrastructure we
highly encourage you to look at other
Google cloud platform services that will
really make running your clusters very
economical and very efficient second we
want you to consider migrating from HDFS
to Google Cloud storage and we'll talk
about why and how third we want to again
encourage you to consider something
called ephemeral clusters ephemeral
clusters are job specific clusters as
contrasted to general plus purpose
clusters that run multiple jobs in a
shared cluster environment so we want to
encourage you to think about those and
we are again going to talk a lot about
them so that's the general outline of
this presentation
let's get the most important things out
of the way very very quickly what are
the benefits of migrating to Google
cloud platform and consider the fact
that I'm saying Google cloud platform I
am NOT saying Google Data cloud data
proc there is a reason for that so let's
see what that means first Google cloud
data product which is what you will be
migrating to is a cloud service so you
get pay as you go and you get vast and
varied scale make sense second it is a
managed service we provision the VMS for
you we provision the clusters for you we
deploy operating systems on them and we
deploy the open source stack on these
nodes which means that you don't have to
do it and you don't have to carry the
administrative overhead to do it third
if you think about cloud data proc that
is Google's implementation of the open
source Hadoop infrastructure let me
define cloud data proc as we talked
about it internally cloud data Prague is
a service managed service to run your
spark and Hadoop jobs that's what it is
if you are trying to migrate from your
on-premise clusters which are running
that opens so stack it's very easy to do
that by just making some minor
modifications to your job code if that's
all you are looking to do you are
focused on a lift and shift strategy
right now it's very simple to do that
but I think where you get value is when
you start implementing our
recommendations that we've just talked
about and I am going to kind of
elaborate on what that value proposition
is okay
the next two four and five really are
about Google cloud platform they're not
about Google Cloud Data proc we just
talked about running ephemeral clusters
which are job specific clusters and what
we are trying to stress there is rather
than deploying a whole bunch of
libraries for running Hadoop and spark
and hive and whatever else that you can
think of we just want you to focus on
the job of interest that means you do
not have library clashes etc etc the
management overhead is low and it really
greases the wheels of your operations
really really well make sense
finally Hadoop has a blind spot and the
blind spot is when you are working with
persistent data it is in HDFS and it is
not very easy to go and unlock the value
of the data and move it to other
platforms where the value really gets
used let me establish a very simple use
case say you just ran a spark job and
the spot job was creating
recommendations for powering your
personalization engine on your website
how do you get that data that your spot
job just generated which is stored in
HDFS out to your recommendation engine
that is a challenge and we with our
whole plethora of different services
actually do that really well and we are
going to talk about this a couple of
different points ok
let's get started section number one
just you're gonna focus on
infrastructure let's step back let's
look at our on premise clusters there
are three characteristics which stand
out for these on premise clusters one
they're monolithic and they have large
number of nodes that you need to make
sure get upgraded and have the right
software in tandem if you don't do that
you have trouble and you know all that
second these are persistent they run for
many days which means it leads to other
kind of management overhead with making
sure that everything all the job
configuration is right and there are no
flashes and nothing has died and
everything is up third these clusters
are shared across jobs teams projects
and that sharing infrastructure leads to
a whole bunch of different problems that
you are probably very aware of I'm not
going to focus on that we're going to
talk about how to solve these problems
the key characteristic which creates a
lot of problems with on-premise clusters
is the fact that they are persistent and
they're shared and we just talked about
data being locked in HDFS and we need to
figure out a way to unlock that so
that's one limitation second HDFS
because of its replication factor 2 3 4
I don't know what you guys are running
with it's expensive third if you are not
using Google cloud platform you have a
opportunity cost
what is that opportunity cost you cannot
use other services that can help unlock
the value inside your clusters make
sense let's look at some solutions now
very simple diagram first of many your
on premise cluster is on the left and
your migrated clusters are on the right
on premise you are running two clusters
for jobs and two HDFS setups when you
are done migrating you will actually
have three clusters job three and four
actually get their own clusters remember
I've been talking about ephemeral
clusters which are job specific which
means one cluster per job so I got three
clusters running and all my data is
stored in Google Cloud storage buckets
so remember I said migrate from SC FS to
GCS use ephemeral clusters this is that
architecture very simple basic we're
gonna build on this but this is a
starting point now before we actually
delve even deeper let's talk about two
very important architectural principles
that are embedded in Google Cloud Data
proc and our migration recommendations
align really really well with those
architectural principles the first
architectural principle is separate your
data from computation
now this particular architectural
principle is not unique to cloud data
proc pretty much all of googles Big Data
Platform
and different offerings bigquery etc
they are built on this architectural
principle now how that translates into
specific things you need to do with
Cloud Data proc or follows first we are
asking you to migrate from HDFS to GCS
that's your separation separate the data
out from the cluster remove it from a
CFS GCS is HDFS compliant which means
there is only slight modifications you
need to make to your code and we will
actually show you what those are and you
are running in cloud data proc but as I
said earlier if all you are looking to
is to do a lift and shift it's a very
simple thing but if you're trying to get
value we will go and talk about other
things
second GCS is faster GCS is definitely
more economical and GCS is very easy to
manage little to no management overhead
and we already talked about the fact
that if you are looking to unlock value
from within HDFS and if you move to GCS
the way it works is most of Google
platform technologies work very
seamlessly with Google Cloud storage
which means that is your venue that is
your door to opening the value from
within cloud from your on-premise
clusters in cloud data proc make sense
let's talk about the second
architectural principle which I have
already talked about three times and I'm
going to talk about ten times more use
ephemeral clusters now if you have jobs
sharing the same infrastructure you have
to do a setup before every job run you
have to make sure that the configuration
for the cluster for that particular job
run is set up right that's quite a bit
of management overhead if I actually am
now running clusters which are job
specific I don't have to do that I just
have to configure that particular job I
also don't have to deploy a whole bunch
of different libraries so if I'm running
a spot job I don't need to deploy Hadoop
libraries or hive libraries make sense
easier to manage the easiest analogy I
can think about this architectural
principle is that old proverb that
you've heard fire is a very poor master
but a great slave or some variation of
that clusters because of all the
limitations
to vote earlier are actually running you
ragged in most cases we are trying to
relieve that pressure by taking control
back over our clusters through the
ephemeral cluster design make sense it's
logical right now what what do you get
with this one that you get first thing
you get is the ability to have very
controlled configurations much finer
control over the jobs second is I can
actually scale my cluster independently
of any other job that I might be sharing
in a shared cluster architecture so I
could deploy a thousand nodes for one
job whereas my cluster itself was 100
nodes earlier huge value unlocking let's
keep going
job specific cluster how does it work I
start my job through cloud data prop API
or to the UI doesn't matter it spins up
a cluster for you which you configured
earlier the job runs it generates data
in this case I'm actually outputting
data to Google bigquery cloud bigquery
and we'll talk about why that is so I
also am storing data in cloud storage I
run my job and once the job is complete
I actually delete the cluster I delete
the cluster can you believe it because
this is a problem we talked about this
diagram earlier that was our simple
starting point life is never simple
simple diagrams don't actually do
justice to the problems we have to face
in the real world let's build on this a
little bit this is my migration and
state the cloud native solution on the
Left in green you see my ephemeral
clusters we just talked about them
job-specific I can have a bunch of them
I don't need one two three
I could have hundreds of them
if need be as required in the middle in
blue you see my different data stores I
already talked about cloud storage I'm
adding two more to this mix it's
bigquery and BigTable B query for those
of you who do not know about it is a
petabyte scale data warehouse and
BigTable is really about managing sparse
data that you want to read and write to
very very fast very low latency read and
write access both of those are now
available for me remember I was talking
about unlocking that value stored in
HDFS that's what we're doing we also are
talking about monitoring and logging get
a little bit better a better idea of
your operations and what you need to
tune as you actually get data from
runtime below my ephemeral clusters you
see an orchestration engine you see
Apache airflow Apache airflow or a
variant like an Azkaban that's what you
can implement for coordinating the flow
of your jobs and their dependencies we
actually have recently g8 a product
called Google Cloud composer and James
has a very very big session in the
afternoon today you want to give some
details about that session yeah so
there's a session at 1:55 on our GA
launch of cloud composer which is a
managed Apache airflow service and the
goal with having to manage matching
airflow service is to solve the cloud
level workflows and orchestrations but
have a product that's open source that
can talk to things inside of google talk
to things outside of Google in that
session we'll be talking about why we
launched composer kind of our vision for
composer if you're new to air flow we'll
be breaking apart an airflow tag and
giving a demo of composer so it's a good
kind of baseline and intro to air flow
and cloud composer if you're curious
and it's at 155 today and I think it's
not quite full but it is almost at
capacity so if you carry us to sign up
for it
yep and now in yellow on the right
yellow or orange whatever you're seeing
I have what's distant plasters what did
I just tell you that you need to go with
the femoral trust or stateless and I'm
telling you you need to have persistent
clusters in this architecture life is
complex we'll talk about it in couple of
seconds say you have a spot streaming
job running it on an ephemeral cluster
is next to impossible
you need a persistent cluster you may
also have a use case where you have a
bunch of different jobs that need to run
together they're dependent on each other
and some of these jobs actually are very
short run they might just be ingesting
data into the cluster itself or into GCS
from a source the overhead of spinning
up a cluster might be much larger than
you want to tolerate that's also a good
case for running maybe a short run
persistent cluster but a persistent
cluster nonetheless makes sense but if
you are going to run a persistent
cluster here are a couple of
recommendations number one scope it to
be the smallest possible cluster that
you can think of in terms of number of
jobs you are going to run and the number
of nodes that are going to be part of
that cluster it's a very very simple
recommendation so we talked about the
underlying components we talked about
architectural principles let's get to
the mechanics first move data to GCS
again I'm repeating it again do it
incrementally and we actually talked
about a couple of strategies in a couple
of minutes second thing is experiment
what does that mean now that I have
actually opened up the architecture for
you I can run job-specific ephemeral
clusters I want you to run proofs of
concept I want you to experiment with
the size of your cluster the number of
nodes try out different configurations
figure out what works best for you in
terms of the dollars that you are
spending the time it takes to run a
particular job because that's a
requirement in many cases I want to go
from 12 hours to 2 hours that's my new
window you can experiment and you can
actually make it happen with cloud data
proc so that's our recommendation
central to all of this is ephemeral
clusters which we have been talking
about over and over again migrating
incrementally ok so what's new anybody
who has been in the world of IT thinks
in terms of eating the elephant in small
chunks right the only guidance up here
is when you are actually creating POCs
or you are defining the scope of your
agile sprint if that's your thing then
think in terms of dependent C's of the
jobs move them together it will actually
make things simple for you remember what
ephemeral clusters are are stateless you
have input you have output there's
nothing inside the cluster itself it
runs it dies it rises up like the
Phoenix and it dies again it's the cycle
of birth and rebirth keeps on going on
with an ephemeral cluster right think
incrementally
let's take actually a look at an
architecture which will help you do that
this architecture is something called a
backfill pipeline are you guys aware of
this have you ever heard of this anybody
yes ok so say you have your big data
stack running for the last three years
recently in the last six months or so
you created a bunch of new jobs but
since your cluster is already running to
capacity you never have the time to go
back and run these jobs against your
my data from two and a half years ago
the idea of a backfill pipeline is to
actually take your jobs and run it
against archived data so how is that
relevant to us remember I've been saying
experiment using your jobs
the newly migrated jobs against archived
data is actually a very good way of
validating it your jobs will run well
they will run correct and you will get
the characteristics you are looking for
in terms of performance times etc etc
make sense so this is one low risk
architecture the key component up here
is that little box in the middle which
says Internet gateway and cloud storage
we are trying to bring data over from
your premise on premise cluster into
cloud data problem that's the key idea
there and we are actually going to
expand on this a little bit further ok
so you are in the middle of a migration
before migration you had your on-premise
cluster after migration you have that
cloud native architecture I talked about
somewhere in the middle both of them are
living together that's the idea behind
hybrid architecture nothing new there
now this hybrid architecture we just
talked about is being imposed on you by
the requirements of being in the middle
of a migration cycle but there might be
business requirements for you to
actually have a hybrid architecture I'll
give you an example one of my customers
is actually running their order
management system on-premise they're
looking to migrate it to the cloud but
the problem is it's going to take a
little bit of time for them to figure
out what that looks like
it's a monolithic system they need to
figure out how to create microservices
etcetera etcetera and do that
appropriate migration so they want to
for the foreseeable future run their
extraction and Big Data jobs relating to
or
in a system in house that's the hybrid
architecture we are talking about
example again ephemeral justice in green
on the Left we have the storage in blue
and we have on-premise yellow on the
right and in the middle is a contraption
from bringing your data over from your
on-premise clusters over into cloud
storage VPN gateways are involved and
some more clusters are involved now
these clusters are for actually copying
the data over from your on-premise
cluster over to cloud storage there are
a couple of mechanisms there it's really
out of scope of this particular
presentation but we will point you to a
couple of links where you can actually
go and take a closer look at them and
maybe this is something where you
actually engage Google professional
services to help you with okay there's a
push and pull kind of an architecture
involved
after three recommendations I gave you
in the big length the first one was look
at a broader portfolio of Google cloud
services let's talk about what are the
considerations their regions say you are
deploying your architecture it's a multi
regional architecture and for some
reason your persistent data in Google
Cloud Storage is sitting in a region
which is separate from where your
resources are located your ephemeral
clusters are located cetera what is
probably going to happen for you is
Google cloud is probably gonna in
certain cases copy the data over from
one region to another
there are latency considerations and
there are cost considerations because of
egress costs and you need to think
through some of that especially if you
are building any kind of dr kind of a
set up okay
all Google cloud services have
stackdriver
logging and monitoring built into them
you can use your on-premise or whatever
tool you are using to bring that data or
you can actually use that driver we
think it's pretty cool so you should
stay with start reiver but it's your
choice finally I have talked about this
multiple times we can store data in
bigquery and in BigTable as needed
section two so we've talked about
infrastructure let's talk very quickly
about data we've been through this a few
times you can migrate data from Apache
HBase to BigTable equivalent
technologies you can migrate data from
Apache Impala to bigquery and if you've
got high running you may want to think
about running your hive meta store on
cloud sequel which is Google's open
source implementation of my sequel X
sense
security you are never going to get the
level of granular control that you get
in HDFS but using google's IM policies
you can have equivalent control over the
data that is stored in Google Cloud
Storage we are recommending that you
apply controls at the level of buckets
not at the level of files but if for
some reason your use case requires that
you work at the level of a file then
think in terms of using GCS ACLs we
don't recommend it but if you have to go
down that path you have to go down that
path make sense speed I process
terabytes of data per day and my VPN
connection is not fast enough or doesn't
have enough bandwidth what do I do
so some people deploy multiple VPN
connections that might solve the problem
for you depending on the data that you
are the volume of data you are working
with or you may want to look at two
alternative technologies to plug into
Google's network direct peering have you
guys been familiar with are appearing
anybody deployed direct bearing is
essentially your ability to tap into
Google's fast network directly through
the point of presence what do we call
them yo peace P or P network set up with
the if you are unable to do that for any
reason you can actually use our partner
services called cloud interconnect
services where a partner actually lays
the cable from their data center which
is kind of collocate located and
connects into Google Network and you can
broaden that bandwidth
make sense so these are the key elements
for data its bandwidth is access control
and where you're storing data let's talk
about jobs remember the first thing I
said was if all you are looking to do is
to migrate your jobs from on-premise to
cloud data proc it's very very simple to
do HDFS those four letters you replace
it with those two letters TS that's all
you need to do it's pretty cool huh we
support these come as default setups but
we are not limited to actually
supporting this so we have something
called initialization actions where you
can define what kind of stack you want
to run and it will add runtime deploy
the stack for you and you can continue
with your running that particular stack
or jobs so these are just the default
configurations available to you but
initialization actions lets you open up
the whole stack right that's correct
something that's not on here that's a
feature that we are releasing in the
next few weeks is the ability to also
pick and choose which components you
would like on your cluster so
canonically right now when you create a
cluster you can specify one or more
initialization actions and those
initialization actions are shell scripts
or anything that can be executed in a
debian environment people have asked for
the ability to do things like tick box
so I want a cluster with SPARC and maybe
add Zeppelin or HBase so in the coming
weeks you'll see when you create a data
proc cholesterol they'll be additional
options you just say create a cluster
with Zeppelin anaconda Olivie whatever
else you want that makes it easier to
create the cluster with the optional
components it also means on the backend
we're testing all of those components
against each data proc image build
that's probably a session in and of
itself because how we build the image is
really interesting but quite a lengthy
process but it also means that we're
testing all of those components against
our weekly image builds to make sure
that they work that things don't break
with each new release of W and each new
release
and source components and all of their
dependencies which can be quite
complicated so it's obstructing away
quite a bit of that complexity for you
so you don't have to worry about it
the key point I wanted to actually
bubble up in this particular slide are
two things one as you migrate from your
on-premise cluster over to ephemeral
clusters you may want to start with the
smallest possible configuration that is
closest to what you were running with
and then do the experiments you might
find that even with a smaller
configuration you might get equivalent
performance you'll be surprised there
the second point I wanted to make was
this point about 3m table instances or
preemptable workers preemptable workers
is really a cool feature where in you
can take discounts of up to 80% on the
regular pricing on instances that Google
if needed be can reclaim back by telling
you that we are actually claiming these
instances but if not you can run some of
your higher latency jobs something that
is not critical at a lower price point
they're very very cool feature final
piece is all about scalability cloud
data proc allows you to scale both up
and down and we also have this concept
of graceful degradation so we actually
let the cluster figure out that it's
ready to scale up or down at them
usually down at the right moment without
crashing nodes and creating problems for
you last piece in this is restartable
jobs data proc also has the intelligence
to figure out if a job has actually
completed or it was aborted for a
plethora of different reasons maybe some
services were not available or you will
have some dependencies that you couldn't
do anything about so you may want to
think about building your jobs or
modifying them slightly so they are
restartable make sense for longer
running jobs say are sparks
job that runs for 20 hours of salt what
you may want to do is use preemptable
instances but build in your own
variation of checkpointing in it so at
the appropriate time save the data into
cloud storage and if for some reason the
instances get preempted and you have to
restart you still haven't lost 15 hours
of work that you did it's not
complicated to do it's very simple and
if any of you guys want to talk about it
we can do that offline make sense now
you've got the Mac migration done we are
wanting to run this on an ongoing basis
what you may want to do is to apply
custom labels for identifying your
clusters cause chargebacks etc etc this
is just a basic feature built into all
of Google cloud platform we've already
talked about organizing GCS buckets to
separate jobs and apply access controls
and finally we've talked about ephemeral
clusters and the ability to run one or
closely related jobs on the same cluster
[Music]